nein
[Musik]
hey leute was genau von herzlich
willkommen beim neuen video ja leute ich
hoffe natürlich euch gut es kann ja
ungefähr von der woche das video von mir
ich kaufe einen automaten leer was ja
nicht so ganz geklappt hat da muss ich
mir erst mal ein bisschen für
entschuldigen gesundheit nachts einfach
los hat nicht funktioniert ich war ein
bisschen angepassten und hab mir gedacht
wir haben immer schon relativ viele
aufnahmen dann nichts das video einfach
so hoch habe wirklich gar nicht richtig
darüber nachgedacht das ist auch
ziemlich viel hält geben kann aber gut
so ist das deswegen habe ich mir aber
gedacht macht das ganze einfach nochmal
und dieses mal richtig ich war ich hier
bei der bank ich habe mehrere banken
abgeklappert das war gar nicht mal so
leicht haben insgesamt 250 euro in so
kleinen röhrchen abgeholt und habe mir
auch schon ein paar automaten zu kommen
lassen habe den besten ausgewählt und da
werden wir heute hinfahren das ding ist
der ist in seiner firma also im vor
gebäude von von dieser firma ich hoffe
wir kommen da auch rein aber es wird
schon irgendwie klappen und harwich ist
auch noch dabei war ganz wichtig noch
wir sind morgen also nicht umsonst sagt
man jetzt morgen einig wir sind diesen
samstag in wien auf der video kommt
gerne vorbei tickets sind in der video
beschreibung verlinkt wird auf jeden
fall cool wenn ihr aus wien kommt der
sehr gern ich war noch nie in wien
vorher also ich das ab und dann sehen
wir uns am samstag also leute wir fahren
jetzt los zum automaten dann bin ich mal
gespannt wie viel ich ausgeben wer hat
also let's go so leute wir sind jetzt da
ich würde sagen wir gehen einfach mal
hin und hoffen dass wir das ohne
probleme machen können aber ich denke
das müsste eigentlich gehen also leute
hier sind jetzt fehlt uns einfach drei
das ding ist das hat halt irgendwie mal
offen und also wie gesagt das ist jetzt
so eine art kantine einfach also wie
kann man irgendwie immer rein irgendwie
so ein keine ahnung wie man es nennt
aber hier haben so irgendwie firmen
darauf zugriff von können hingegen auf
jeden fall zeige ich euch mit den
automaten
ich habe mir dann halt vorher schon mal
angeguckt einfach weil es in köln so
viele automaten gibt und manche die sind
einfach so vor allem die an den
hauptbahnhöfen und so da passt keine
ahnung da musst du wirklich 1000 euro
bezahlen dass das ganze ding nähert und
ich hab gesucht der am automat ich habe
keine ahnung wie viel jetzt tun ist ich
zeige dir einfach mal also es ist auf
jeden fall schon eine menge auch hier
unten diese dinger gehen wirklich bis
ganz nach hinten zum beispiel hier
dieses was ist das schoko rice habe ich
noch nie gesehen also wir haben jetzt
mal wieder
ich will haben wir fast 30 wir haben
halb elf und ich würde sagen wir starten
macht mir dass man sagen muss das ist
ganz wichtig schreibt jetzt auf jeden
fall noch mal wieder eure schätzungen
die kommentare was glaubt ihr wie teuer
wie das sein
ich habe es euch ja schon eben gesagt
das habe ich noch gar nicht gezeigt ich
war bei der bank und habe hier
ordentlich im geld geholt habe insgesamt
200 euro abgeholt mit 250 euro sogar
weil ich jetzt halt wirklich durchziehen
will
ich kann mir das mal irgendwie danach
und bisschen dunkler dass ich es nicht
hinbekommen habe ich glaube 170 euro
380 380 die ja was da steht aber auch
gar nicht dran wie teuer das ist ne 32
80 cent dass das ja vor günstig wo man
zuerst ist ein koloss
ich würde sagen wir fangen am mittag mit
dem m und 1 ab so meine tüte habe ich
wieder dabei
da kommt alles
und heute von heute geht es auch
wirklich schneller beim letzten mal das
hat so lange gedauert wenn ihr das
letzte video noch nicht gesehen habt
schaut euch das erst mal an meine karte
wird einfach gesperrt weil ich die ganze
zeit diese karte daran gehalten habe
weil ich kein kleingeld hat
also ich mache jemand alles leer wie
vorstellen das ganze mal weil das video
soll ja nicht 30 minuten gehen
ich will jetzt meine kommentare
schreiben was glaubt ihr wie lange
dauert das stellt euch dann am ende man
die zeit ein irgendwie so viele sms kann
ich gar nicht in zwei wochen trifft nun
im film aber so vom rhein liegen die
leute morgen hier um alles
na ja klar da ich auch so dass wir
toleranz walten passiert also einer
denkt sich mal pro woche erstmals geräte
[Musik]
also wie man sehen kann die mittlere
reihe jetzt schon komplett leer
ich würde sagen mach mal schön weiter
jetzt kommen gummibärchen
also wir verstellen das ganze nochmal
weiter geht's heute alle die diese
schoko warf dann kennen geben jetzt mal
nach oben
[Musik]
aber ein schuss von dieser automaten
erregt sich morgen auch so was ist das
denn käsekuchen die leute das ist
einfach käsekuchen das habe ich dann
gesehen
heute schaut euch das mal an
[Musik]
wir haben einfach 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13
wir haben ja einfach jetzt 15 ticks
heute ist das erste getränk für eine
cola zu kommen ein daumen
schaut euch das mal wie es aussieht
[Musik]
leute das letzte tipps das waren einfach
15 stück ja und die marktleute kurzer
zwischenstand also ich hab jetzt genau
100 euro ausgeben bis jetzt also ich
habe noch ein bisschen mehr meistens
jedoch schon weg bin ich mir und noch
ein paar reihen und mal sehen wie lange
das noch so hat man fängt auf jeden fall
bei der arbeit auch an zu schwitzen
das ist richtig wie sagt man
hochleistungssport genau
[Musik]
ja
daher macht immer weiter an boden
gewinnen müssen bisschen an meinen
körper denken deswegen bitte einen
abgesagt damit ich würde dann abgesagt
jede menge drin
danke leute wir sind bei den letzten
beiden rennen ein und energy drinks
einmal wissen mit heute ist ein euro
leute wir befinden uns auf den letzten
metern
wir haben noch drei wallis tus fiel das
los unserem kalender südrings
angefertigt und das ist auch mein
letztes geld dann sind 250 aber das
alles für guten zweck dass wir alles
gespendet an leute die sich darüber
freuen also da kann keiner was sagen
[Musik]
es sind aber kein bisschen
sollte das problem ist dass ganze
wechselgeld fällt immer hier rein
leute wir haben insgesamt noch sieben
stück oder nicht nur drei stück noch
oder 334 leute waren jetzt ihr bestimmte
stunde oder so und dann ist das ding
leer einmal bis jetzt trommelwirbeln und
irgendwelche special effects
mit
wir haben jetzt hier insgesamt sechs
sieben acht neun zehn elf zwölf
insgesamt 238 euro und das ganze ding
ist leer
ich weiß gar nicht was ich sagen wir
haben wir noch gar nicht alles in den
typen
nein nein nein nein
er sagt nicht dein handy aber nimmt am 1
ein dass wir in einer damit sich ein
witz darüber freuen
leute das war's wir sind fertig jetzt
geht's nach hause
das ist echt schwer das ist das lied ich
nicht
alles klar leute jetzt erst mal nach
hause ist gleich am morgen das ist mir
gemacht leute der hat geht es in eine
tüte mit nach oben genommen
die andere ist nur im auto aber 170
teams
ich habe mir gedacht ich fliege nach
österreich ein bisschen davon nehmen wir
mit und verteilen das an die leute die
vorbeikommen stimmrechte müssen jetzt
los wenn schon 512 gleich ein bisschen
was als natürlich auch selber aber den
rest also vor allem das was unserem auto
lieber ich halt irgendwem geben der sich
darüber freut ihr könnt ja meine
kommentare schreiben wenn man so viele
süßigkeiten hin bringen kann
letztes mal habe ich ja ein bisschen was
davon in der stadt verteilt habe ich
zwar dieses mal auch wieder machen aber
schreibt gerne in die kommentare was man
sonst noch damit machen kann vielleicht
wir müssen jetzt los du hast noch eine
halbe stunde
warum ist das so ausgebreitet was also
das was mit dem video wie gesagt wir uns
geht es jetzt nach wien kommt vorbei auf
die video kommen würde uns sehr freuen
und